[Musica]
ad ogni luna piena tornerà il lupo
mannaro non è fantastico quante saranno
le tappe soprattutto dove dobbiamo
andare prima al castello forse o poi
avete sentito qualcosa va bene
[Musica]
no
ciao ragazzi purtroppo siamo tornati a
casa anche se io sto riguardando il
vestito da principessa è sognando ancora
di essere al castello ma purtroppo siamo
quando tutti a torino di tutti grazie
merlino mida sembri tanti baci c'è un
problema però anche se abbiamo fatto col
viaggio siamo stati nel castello siamo
stati al parco dei mostri abbiamo visto
i lupi abbiamo superato pari al
challenger ma non abbiamo ancora vinto
la sfida finale se ricordi nella prima
lettera diceva che dovevo vincere la
sfida finale il problema è che sta per
tornare alla luna piena
guarda al tramonto e vero mi sto
avvicinando la notte come faremo adesso
beh forse facciamo in tempo a trovare
una soluzione prima che arrivi la luna
piena e miri trasformi di nuovo vi
ricordate l'ultima volta che mitola
trasformata che cosa è successo
rischi di mangiare vitale intero si io
me lo ricordo bene però io non voglio
essere mangiato io voglio voglio
mangiare invece non sembra ti sembra il
momento di pensare a mangiare adesso
potrebbe trasformarmi in un lupo mannaro
completo e tu potresti essere sbranato
di non trovare una soluzione subito sari
il re ha lasciato qualche lettera o
forse voleva e io mi ritrasformarsi per
completare la sfida finale
non lo so lo dobbiamo sbrigarci
chiediamo come sempre un berlino che lui
sta tutto sei merlino
berlino dividete aiutate in tutte le
nostre challenge dove potresti dirci
come devo fare per non trasformarsi in
lupo valdaro l'orecchio grazie con i
balzini ma che cosa vorrà dire aspetta
aspetta aspetta voluto leader sa magari
visto che sta diventando buio adesso
dirti ritrasformi se ti porto qualcosa
da mangiare a così mangi dopo se ti
trasformi non mangerai me non so se si è
capito però ti do da mangiare prima così
non mangimi e dopo non credo che
funzioni ma possiamo provare lo stesso
non abbiamo altre alternative che vado a
prendere subito colpito per ciao ragazzi
secondo voi
vitale è andato in cucina davvero a
portarmi da mangiare oppure era una
scusa per andare lui a mangiare
[Musica]
trasformazione già iniziata
enoch di già iniziato l'altro giorno
stavo cadendo rete un nuovo lido ve lo
portate queste per per cercare di
fermare la sua fame la tua fano caso
michael tumi mangi visto che poi avremmo
adesso spiega vi è una cosa che cosa
perché i portato le fate a fine per me l
stai mangiando tu perché subito
trasformato armani nolan è stato già
trasformato sono spuntate le ore che
mancano ancora i denti aguzzi gli occhi
gialli le tasse
la coda e poiché soltanto sera non mi
riconosco
qui c'è la trasformazione completa in
cui divento un lupo mannaro zappino e
vengo a cercarti sto mandando tenere
nascosto ho capito devo trovare uno solo
che sta succedendo un po troppo tardi o
no forse amo esco fuori prudentino di
macchiare fuori truccato cari
magari posso prendere anche per cibo sì
sì mi sembra un'ottima idea sempre un
momento di stand devo dire mi sembra
un'ottima idea la tua di uscire fuori
così almeno posso stare un pacchetto con
dentro gara dato che strano eppure mi
sento ancora me stessa sento come
l'istinto da lungo vitale noi è come
farlo tornare partite tipo
come rosetta offende dio per la tua
incolumità vado a chiuderli fuori in
giardino due periti chiude a chiave
sembra si segnala l'ottima idea molto
per la doccia infuriato scrittore la
metto dalla trasformazione
sperando di non riuscire a entrare
dentro casa durante la notte con la luna
piena e arriva la mattina e tu sei
ancora vino per andato tutto bene subito
devo assolutamente pensare a qualcosa
cosa posso fare
all'inter proprio là fuori guardate vi
faccio vedere
le cose non stanno andando per il verso
giusto non la vedo più andiamo video con
me eccoci qua siamo vicino alla porta
[Musica]
1 seggio trascorre padre organista come
ti senti era forse meglio se chiude la
porta o no cerca di prendermi
che cosa sta facendo sta perdendo le
mosche no sta entrando dentro casa
quindi se esco fuori anita mi mangia se
ne sto dentro e aspetto è arriva la luna
piena e anita si trasforma del tutto c'è
solo una persona che può aiutarmi ad
esso vi ricordate chi è
possiamo chiamarlo the great e facciamo
lupo grazie di essere venuto ad aiutarmi
ecco vedi sta arrivando la luna piena
nella vita da fuori e si sta
trasformando
tutto procede secondo i piani ai sei
sicuro è unita ed iva che si sta
trasformando il lupo la luna piena sta
arrivando
ok mi fido di te allora ma sei sicuro
che non ci sia un'altra soluzione ne sei
proprio sicuro quindi questa è l'unica
soluzione
vorrei trovare una soluzione un pochino
più indolore non posso fare
qualcos'altro magari possiamo fare
qualcos'altro insieme
bene allora fa in modo che sia rapido e
una cosa devo fare io
io devo andare alla vita cioè da lupo
mannaro e portarla qui e come faccio se
vado fuori mi strana
[Musica]
quindi devo trovare una soluzione per
attirare la vita dentro e io rimanere
fuori
chiedo può rimanere fuori dalla porta
penso di potercela fare la tirerò alla
porta mi faccio seguire fino qui nel
frattempo scatta glielo diano qualche
parte ok allora facciamo così tu
nasconditi no non è bisogno giustamente
non hai bisogno che il lupo ti lascio
qui è arrivo cioè nel senso arriva a
carità
ciao ragazzino ho avuto un'idea geniale
per prendere anita cioè il lupo mannaro
ho pensato di travestirmi di campo il
centro rosso aspettate poi si fa male
meglio cosa per attirare un lupo se non
travestirsi da cappuccetto rosso
ecco guardate gli manca solo il cestino
e biscotti ma meglio così perché
altrimenti mi sarei maggio di tutti
cerchiamo anita magari a cui da qualche
parte che si nasconde in mezzo agli
alberi e non nasconderci
[Musica]
ci ho provato a controllare un po qui ma
non vedo proprio nulla quindi magari
adesso mi sposto
sento dei passi dietro di me c'è
qualcuno dietro di me
lo stesso andando nella direzione
sbagliata e meglio a chi era da un'altra
parte o di così non posso vedo più
niente
così la posso tirare dentro casa formate
tra il lupo
[Musica]